uh you've been super so I feel like for
so long you were just sitting on a bunch
of music and every time I'd see you
you'd play me [ __ ] and I'd be like when
are you gonna put some [ __ ] out yeah
it's time you've been on well you've
been on a tear you've been putting out
singles you obviously dropped the
project with Burn yeah um that did
really well uh you've been working with
everybody from burner to Davies to
Jeremiah to [ __ ] uh goddamn French
Montana I mean we could go on and on
um
you got a new mixtape coming out yeah so
um like you said I've been working on a
lot of music this mixtape dropping on
the 16th uh me and Justin credible got
together
um really it started with him you know
he started doing like mixtapes on some
old you know what DJ Clue type of [ __ ]
he wanted to kind of get in the music
side of things
earlier this year he put out this
project called hunger flow and he hit me
for like you know I mean I did like a
little freestyle joint on there and then
I saw he's working on a second one and I
had this song called 10 rap Commandments
I shot it to him like yo if you want to
use it you know what I mean and he loved
it he put it on his [ __ ] and then we
were just talking he's like yo we should
do more [ __ ] together you know and I saw
he did a he did a tape with the Russell
which was really like his first one like
that you know I mean with like one
artist
it was called just incredible presents
La Russell I'm like yo let's go Justin
credible presents armeen I have a lot of
music so we put put a really dope
project together on dsps or is it like
yeah yeah it's not like on some sound
[ __ ] yeah no there's no freestyles on
famous beats or anything like that yeah
we can't do that now I mean [ __ ] people
are doing it yeah I don't know why but
they are yes it's not the wave like yeah
you could do it put in our YouTube
SoundCloud it just don't reach as many
people you know what I mean like I feel
like I made that mistake in the past you
know I mean